[Music]
how do you just find like what you do
you're not a motivational speaker like
where do you fall in what what like what
bucket would you say you've fallen in
terms of what you do for a living I'm
just let's just start with with that and
then we're gonna
delve into hopefully lots of other stuff
so I mean my my immediate reactions to
say I'm an optimist you know I I Define
Myself by who I am not what I do
and I think that one of the big
challenges that a lot of people face is
they they intertwine their identity with
their work yeah I am a lawyer you know
yeah I am a fitness coach or whatever
you know somebody wants to do and then
if you lose that job by your choice or
not your own choice or if you have great
success and you get older and you decide
to leave and retire or do something else
I see a lot of people have an identity
crisis because they no longer do the
thing that they did yeah and so I don't
mind what I do uh because I get to be an
optimist in everything that I do
um uh and
I you know I the way I live my life is
is I I live completely focused with a
vision that is extremely far away
completely I'll never get there you know
I imagine a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired feel safe wherever they
are and and the day fulfilled by the
work that they do and for me the
objective is to figure out all the ways
that I can to start moving closer and
closer towards that world and so
um for the better part of the last you
know
decade or more I I bet on the cons on
leaders I believe that the leader is the
best bet that we have to get to that
world that I imagine that if we can find
and celebrate and support the kinds of
leaders who can build great
organizations uh where people feel like
they belong that feel like they're
contributing something bigger than
themselves then we are more likely to
get to that world right now what's my
role in that
again completely agnostic I never ever
imagined that I would be an author I was
never one of those people who thought I
had a book in them you know and after uh
every book I've written uh I've said
okay that's probably my last one and I
said that after the first one you know
um uh but here I am an author because
the opportunity
um uh showed up that I thought oh this
is a good way to move towards that
vision
right
um and people would invite me to speak
about my ideas and I thought okay never
ever wanted to be a public speaker
didn't even know that was a career you
know it's true interesting right I I uh
um uh I actually am more of a behind the
scenes person I've never desired to be
on the front of a proscenium
um but when the opportunities presented
themselves I thought well this is a very
good way for me to spread this message
right and to spread this vision and so
so when you ask me what do I do
I do anything that I need to do to
advance towards that Vision these days
I'll write books and I'll speak about it
um but who knows what the next five
years will look like it could be
completely completely different well
almost okay so in that one answer I have
now isn't that annoying that you say
what do you do and it takes me 30
minutes yeah exactly I actually have a
friend who did a Ted Talk on this like
when someone asks you that question of
what do you do to how to like do an
elevator pitch well I can tell you what
I say on an airplane and somebody says
okay yeah I say I teach leaders and
organizations how to inspire people
all right that's good and if they
believe what I believe they say
inspiration that's cool how do you do
that
and we can talk about my work for as
long as they can stand it
um and if they don't believe what I
believe they say what kind of company
what kind of what kind of organizations
so it's a great filter yeah immediately
I know if they're on the same wavelength
as me or not do people recognize you in
airplanes uh these days yeah yeah they
do well okay first of all my I guess to
go back even further than I was going to
was did you even when your Ted Talk is
probably what the number two or three
most viewed of all time right like 80
million 100 million by now something
insane I don't know I don't know if it's
that high but yeah it's done well yeah
it's pretty and then of course being I'm
sure it's actually even higher because
it's been shared and shared and shared
right yeah but were you even shot like
how did that even like because that
takes you I did a TED Talk recently a
couple years ago and that was considered
a viral Ted talk with like 5 million or
6 million and that like put my life on a
different trajectory I can't even
imagine with your type of success in
that Ted Talk would you were you
completely floored at like the response
that that it had
yes and no is the simple answer okay
I had is there ever a simple answer with
you sometimes okay the answer is yes or
no you know I had been giving versions
of that talk for three years oh before I
actually did the tedx okay I've never
done it that short right you know there
were hour-long versions and so I knew
that the message had resonance and I and
and I'd been asked so many of the
difficult questions that I worked out a
lot of The Kinks and the thinking so I
knew that the message had resonance I
knew that people liked it so so I knew
that okay but I never expected uh this
this rinky-dink Ted Talk tedx talk that
I did in you know in a hangar and Puget
Sound with like a 50 or 100 people in
the room you know where
the camera wasn't it's very low quality
right you know my microphone breaks in
the middle of me talking you know me too
you know like literally like training up
mics you know I remember seeing that
that was hilarious and and it's living
proof that things can go wrong and it'll
be fine yeah uh totally fine so I I
didn't know that the tedx talk would do
what it did okay and back then it was
unheard of to put a tedx on the main Ted
website so they only put them on YouTube
right and there was a separate page for
tedx talks just on YouTube you know and
then the main TED Talks would just be on
the Ted ted.com and it very quickly
became the most watched tedx of all
and then they put it on ted.com
and I only found out that they were
going to do that a week before they did
it so and then it continued to grow you
know extremely fast so yeah that was all
a shock to me that was all a surprise to
me I never imagined I knew the message
had resonance resonance I never knew
that it was gonna do that that was a
surprise yeah so before you did that I
mean you said you were doing these big
these talks anyway so you were already
doing public speaking at some level
right so what so just walk me through
because I'm actually very curious about
you before you do you know what I mean
like that's what I'm really kind of
curious about so
you didn't you were like disgruntled
with your career a little bit right I
wouldn't say disgruntled I'd fallen out
of love yeah okay I was I had no passion
for my career okay this was a chosen
career like I started my own business in
the category in a profession that I
thought I wanted to spend the rest of my
life in marketing oh okay you know and
uh and to wake up one morning
with a superficially good life I owned
my own business we had amazing clients
we did really good work our clients
liked us and didn't want to do it
anymore right it's kind of distressing
because as I as I said where we started
you know so many of us intertwine our
identities with our work and if I don't
like my work then who am I right and so
I went through that
um which uh was incredibly unfun
um and it was the discovery of this of
this little idea that I called the
Golden Circle you know where we all know
what we do some of us know how we do it
but very few of us know why we do what
we do and I realized I didn't know why I
was doing what I was doing
um and it was uh it was that crisis
that was designed to do nothing more
than help me find my own passion to get
back my my mojo
um that put me in a path that was um
unexpected
um uh my my entire career is an accident
you know amazing um I am living proof
that uh that you can that you don't have
to have a plan right right right exactly
and it worked out for you right you have
to have a vision you have to have a
vector you have to have a Direction but
you definitely don't need to know the
individual steps so you kind of answered
earlier well before I even go into that
you said something in when your first
answer to me which I thought was
interesting that you're not defining
Yourself by uh what you do but the
problem I find in today's time anyway
it's very everything's kind of very much
dovetails like who you are what you do
what you do is really who you are so you
become friends with the people you work
with or who are aligned with what you do
there's very little separation in that
so I'm interested in how you've in what
how are you able to like
compartmentalize that a little bit you
know what I mean because I find it very
difficult like what I do it's not two
things happen I think that other people
compartmentalize you as well so if I was
a health and fitness person but I'm also
this thing and that thing and that thing
the other like outside from that people
pigeonhole you so it's very hard to
break away you're saying that like
you're you're not really defined by what
you do but you know what you want or how
like you're being an optimist how how
what kind of advice or would you suggest
for other people out there because I
think that there's a lot of confusion
and people do get pigeonholed and or
they don't know the different like they
are they're confused because like you
said they are what they do and so
there's no distinction yeah I still get
pigeonholed you know
um people know me as the thing that is
familiar
you know and
um so I remember in the early days you
know when the only thing I could talk
about was starting with why yeah um when
I started to have more ideas and
different ideas and I would pitch to
these
um prospective uh engagements I'd like
to talk about something new they'd all
say no because right because they wanted
me to do the thing that they knew was
good they wouldn't let me try something
new and so
um I I just arbitrarily picked one and
basically didn't do as I was told
and decided to do something new on the
stage and I think there's um and I'm you
know I'm not Advocate I'm not saying
there's a one size fits all here you
know there's a there's a risk tolerance
but I like testing things in real life
um you know many of my ideas
um are from real life scenarios where
it's not like practice practice okay
it's ready for the real world now
um you know there have been more than
one occasion where I've walked out on
stage and go okay they they they brought
me in to talk about this but I'm having
some new ideas are you guys okay if I
try talking about this it might
completely fail I just wanted to get
some you know some and like people
especially you pick your audiences you
pick a room full of entrepreneurs right
you know they're fine with it you know
right right right if I pick a room full
of Engineers maybe not you know right uh
but maybe not you know maybe Engineers
are fine with that too
um uh and so and then I would try new
things
and
um and you know I
I think I think what makes it work
is very often when we do these things we
show up with a selfish disposition
right I hope they like me I hope they
like my work I hope they buy my book I
hope they you know go to my website I
hope they follow me on social media and
and we act that way you know we put us a
picture behind us on the PowerPoint and
it has our all of our social media
handles on it and has a phone number and
a website and an email address right and
we say at the end you know somebody
asked questions like you know question
whatever and they and we reply well
you'll have to read my book or well
that's on that's from my book you know
and it's like it's we we put ourselves
and that's people can tell
and in those cases we're not rooting for
you in fact we're going to try and trip
you up right because we can't help
ourselves it's entertaining yes you know
you put yourself at the front we'll have
fun with that and so I've I've learned
early to show up with a givers mentality
um where I don't care if uh if they like
me I don't care if they buy a book I
don't care if they follow me on social
media or not all I know is is I have
something that I think is really
valuable and I'm gonna give it to you I
want to give it to you and I believe I'm
giving you with all of my Gusto and all
of my energy and so like I remember you
know people would apologize because they
you know they said there's going to be
this size event and like only half the
number of people showed up and they're
apologizing and I know a lot of speakers
who'd get angry you promised me this
size audience and I was like well I just
feel sorry for the people who didn't
show up because the people who did show
up are gonna get all of me right you
know
um I hold back nothing
um and I think when you show up with a
giver's heart and I literally will say
that before I go out on a stage I would
literally say under my breath before I
step on the stage you're here to give I
will remind myself
that what I'm about to do is is an act
of generosity I think I have something
pretty and I want to share it and people
can tell yeah authenticity people can
tell and so you you have a wide birth
when you show up with a giver's heart
you can make mistakes and you can
stumble over your words and you can you
can talk a little bit too much like I am
right now and people are just fine with
it yeah you know
um so I think you know we're highly
attuned social animals and if you show
up to give you you can you believe it or
not you can you can experiment a lot how
do you how could someone change that
though right like if you're innately
someone who doesn't think like that
right like I'm here to give because
you're right like human I think human
nature some I want to sell my book go
check out my handle do this do that do
that how do you shift like your your
mindset how do you can you train your
brain to think differently like that so
it is authentic because you by just
saying it doesn't make it so correct
right of course you can train yourself
like I wish I could be hell healthy but
you know there's so many things and I'm
just not a healthy person and you know
can I ever be healthy of course of
course you just practice it like you
just start yes of course and it may not
work the first five or ten times you
know you go to the gym a bunch of times
in a row you will see no results right
you know like these things sometimes
take time it's the same you know I the
best I can sum it up when I really
started to learn this lesson was
um uh many years ago I had a meeting at
the Pentagon of all places with a big
fancy General
and I was waiting in the in the foyer
just waiting for for him and have you
ever had it where you where you go to a
meeting or a pentagon no well I mean
you've had meetings
um and somebody comes to get you yeah to
take you to the conference room or the
or the or the or the or the office or
whatever and you have hallway talk
because walking quietly down the hallway
is too uncomfortable yeah and so you
have hallway talk which is nonsense it's
things like how's you know hot day out
today or did you have an easy trip
it's just nonsense and as soon as you
walk into the room that ceases right
well that's what happened to me the
general came to get me and we were
walking back to his office and the
hallway talk ensued and he said
you know Simon um I had everyone in my
office read your book and I said my
publisher thanks you and he said tell
them not to bother I had them read my
copy
that's what he said she said to me so I
learned total Book Sales one total
impact huge versus I go to an event and
they give away 500 free copies of my
book but they use them as you know
coasters and door stops total Book Sales
500 total impact zero
and so I had to learn that it's not
always easy to measure the impact that
we have in the short term now I know
over the long term Book Sales do are a
reflection of the value of my ideas and
whether people want them otherwise it
would just stop selling like I know over
the time but in the short term literally
it tells me nothing and I think too many
of us confuse that the short-term
impacts that we're having are producing
long-term value or conversely having no
short-term impact means we're having no
value and so I treat it like exercise
which is which is
um uh I know that process the process
matters so for example you can't go to
the gym for nine hours and get into
shape it literally doesn't work right no
matter how much effort you put in but if
you work out every single day for 20
minutes
guaranteed 100 you will get into shape
right when will you get into shape no
clue right no one knows over time and
everyone's different some people a
little quicker some people a little
slower and yet we are 100 sure 100 it'll
100 work
just don't know when and we're also
obsessed with predicting when it has to
be this quarter it has to be the end of
the year it has to be when we pay taxes
it has whatever it is like you know and
and I got very comfortable saying I know
that if I stick to the process
work out every day for 20 minutes I know
100 it's going to work and I have to get
comfortable that I have no control over
when
some sometimes quicker sometimes slower
and so the things that I wrote about and
start with why is the game plan that I
have followed since I first wrote about
it since I first started talking about
it I do start with why when somebody
says what do you do I don't sell them
what I do I tell them what I believe and
I wrote about the law of diffusion of
Innovations which is a religion for me
and explain what that is so all
populations sift across the standard
deviation the whole the the old bell
curve right if you have high performance
in a population you're gonna have low
performance you can have an average
always right well the law of diffusion
tells us that the first two and a half
percent of any population are your
innovators is your big idea people right
then the next uh about thirteen and a
half percent of your population or early
adopters these people are very
comfortable
um spending extra money time energy
making some sort of sacrifice to be a
part of something that's bigger than
themselves that reflects who they are
then you have the majority the early
majority in the late majority a little
more cynical a little more practical you
know what's in it for me
um will I get my money back if it
doesn't work you know will I get in
trouble you know that kind of thing you
know a little more risk-averse and then
finally the last 16 you have your
laggards the only reason they do
anything is because you basically don't
have a choice anymore right what the law
of diffusion tells us is that if you
want to have mass Market success if you
want an idea to spread or be sticky
um
you have to achieve between uh 15 and 18
Market penetration and then a social
phenomenon happens called a Tipping
Point and it just goes but because most
of us want the majority we aim all of
our efforts at the majority which
actually doesn't work because the
majority will not try something new
until somebody else has tried it first
right and so as soon as I learned that I
became obsessed with early adopters
and you know I get accused now people
say oh but you can afford to turn work
down I'm like no no I've been targeting
work down when I was leaving living hand
to mouth like I needed every gig I could
get because I was broke and I had no
money in my bank account like you are
totally yeah I mean I was literally
living paycheck to paycheck and and when
was this I mean just when I first
discovered start with Y remember I I
walked away from a marketing business
that I had a lot passion for uh lost
passion for when I discovered this start
with why I think I decided to make
myself the guinea pig and I shut down my
marketing company so I I had no
discernible so you did shut shut it down
I was gonna ask you that I shut it down
I had no discernible good luck I had no
discernible income and so I was I was
literally like scraping it together
um but you had clients you just decided
to walk away from them you just didn't
want to do it anymore yeah yeah okay so
it wasn't for because like the business
was like flailing it and it was flailing
because when you have no passion for
something it turns out it makes it a lot
harder right so I mean you know it's
like yes I lost my passion the business
was flailing yeah
um
um I probably wouldn't have gone out of
business but it definitely felt that way
right you know but um turning down all
this business so so I'll give you a real
life example you know I got very very
good at Discerning who was a Believer
and who wasn't who was early adopter and
who wasn't so go back to the the
elevator pitch you know what do you do I
teach leaders and organizations how to
inspire people if they hear the word
inspire okay they believe what I believe
if they don't hear the word inspire they
don't believe what I believe right it's
what wavelength are we on the same
wavelength and I remember I actually
this is a true story
I remember somebody this is early days
there was no start with why book there
was no start with white Ted Talk and I
was just sort of like trying to figure
it out and I was doing consulting
um doing why Discovery stuff
and uh I remember a guy called me
and he said um
I got your phone number from someone uh
convince me why I should hire you
right and I did not go into sales pitch
mode
because it went through my head is this
guy's not an early adopter this guy will
not help me spread my message
this guy is wants to be convinced and I
literally said
um I kind of I can't help you you know
come on convince me I said there's
nothing I can say or do
that will convince you that you and I
should work together I'm the wrong I'm
the wrong guy for you right and I never
worked with them now I needed the client
but he was the wrong client and I'd
rather struggle just a little bit longer
to find the right person to work with
because when I found the right people to
work with even if I made a little less
money what they did is they told five
people about me or 10 people about me
but they did more than that they told
the right people about me right or they
made introductions by saying Simon
there's somebody you need to meet and
they would tell their friends you need
to meet this person right which is way
more powerful than me saying anything
that ever comes from an objective third
party and so other people were
responsible for my message spreading
other people responsible for the people
I met other people responsible for
helping me to sell the book you know I
had no PR machine or anything like that
right it was people you know I remember
going in the early days I would ask the
audience you know how many of you have
seen the Ted Talk and a lot of people
raised their hands and I said how many
people were scented by someone else and
that number is usually around 75 percent
so these people weren't even tedsters
right you know somebody said oh my God
you know who would love this and they
would send it to their friend yeah and
that's all the law of diffusion and so
there's nothing that I'm doing that's
mythical or magical
right
um there's social phenomena
that I've written about other people
have written about the law of diffusion
is not my idea it's Emmett Rogers in the
1960s you know
um
um the only thing that I did like
anything that works is I had the
discipline to do it that's right you
want to get into shape you have to have
the discipline to do it you want to be
healthy you have to have the discipline
to do it and so and you have to get
comfortable that you cannot predict when
success happens you just have to believe
that the process works and you stick to
the process that's all I did and
everything that it is written about in
that book yeah that's literally the
thing that I followed so you actually so
you believe number one and you had the
discipline to kind of follow it through
it's hard to turn down now look it's not
a perfect system like even someone who's
very healthy sometimes wants to have a
big piece of chocolate cake yes but you
do it with eyes wide open like you know
this puts you slightly out of balance
you know that you might have to do a
little extra work to get it out of your
system and you also know you can do it
now and then but you can't do it every
day right right so did I do business
with clients I shouldn't have of course
I did right but a human for God's sakes
and or if I needed to pay bills right
but I did it with eyes wide open not
believing that this was gonna like set
me up and I was doing it for a short
term because I needed a little infusion
of sugar right you know and I knew not
to do it too often so it's it's the same
mentality yeah it is the same mentality
it's just very hard to do and people
like to take the short-term
gratification quick fix all the time
especially in today's time I feel like I
don't know what I do know what you think
but I feel like when I grew up you know
I don't know what you think it was a
different mentality like than it is
today like people's work ethic isn't as
as strong if I was to be honest but I
think
um what I call it's very much like a
coddle culture type of world right now
where uh everyone like always gets a
participation trophy people are offended
very easily it's very very different
it's hard to I feel it's hard to lead in
a world like that and it's hard to like
work in a world like that when you have
so many
think I feel so many constraints around
the other people right like nobody wants
nobody wants to work but also nobody
wants to nobody nobody wants to be given
Direction everyone wants to be a leader
everyone wants to be an entrepreneur but
yet nobody wants to put in the
discipline the hard work and the effort
have you noticed this might yourself
even though you are very optimistic
about of course people of course
um
of course I mean each generation is
different they have their you know
advantages and disadvantages I think the
thing that sums up all of those what I
would call symptoms mm-hmm
listing is there's a
a deep ingrained in patience this
younger generation that previous
generations seem to have less of you
know you you suggest to a young kid why
don't you take a gap year before College
you know and the thought of taking a
year off literally what the thought that
goes through their mind is I'm I might
but then I'll be behind in my career
right you know um missing the value that
you actually bring from a year off to go
explore as traveler you know
um work even
um or I have to have the perfect job out
of the gate and everything has to go
perfectly and I have to get promoted
quickly because if I don't I'm going to
be behind and you know you know reaching
25 26 27 years old and having this
quarter life crisis and panic which you
know previous generations didn't really
have quarter life crises
um you know
um where you feel like oh my God what my
what what's my career what's my life you
know it's like there's this strange
impatience and it probably comes from
growing up in a world of instant
gratification you know where you know
years before social media if you wanted
to go on a date
you know first you had to meet them
somewhere right you had to be like hey
you know yes and like somebody had to
muster up the courage to ask and
somebody at the most of the courage to
go and it was it took a little bit of
time yes to get a first date a little
bit of flirting a little bit of you had
to learn something right socialization
socialization where now you just swipe
right and I got a date instantly like
I'm feeling a little lazy I'm just you
know there's nothing on TV oh look I got
a date exactly right
um you know shopping
you just go on Amazon and it literally
shows up the next day or the same day or
the same day in some cases you know even
early online shopping you know you'd buy
something and two weeks later it would
show up you know and totally and now
it's now it's the next day
um uh and we're kind of just used to
that we're kind of used to you know we
even information you know like you're
sitting at dinner you're like who's that
actor hold on
right or Alexa who is so important right
I have unlimited access to unlimited
information I did that with you by the
way not for me but for my nine-year-old
oh yes
uh aside I wish they would add the word
please at the end of Alexa yes that
would be nice wouldn't it you know Alexa
turn on the lights please yes otherwise
it won't work different different
conversations tell a lot of Jeff Bezos
that next time you talked please just
tell Jeff to please us please yeah so um
by the way have you ever talked to the
Amazon to talk about them all the time
as an example of like company and blah
blah and lots of the talks you do did
you ever do any kind of like speaking
anything with them or learn I haven't oh
yeah
or with Jeffy so I'm going to write that
down okay
okay email Jeff yeah I'm going to
um so I you know I think it's you know
it's we're all products of our childhood
you know we're in our environment and
our environments were all molded by the
experiences we have and the experiences
around us when we're younger and they
affect our world view and I think if you
grew up in a world of instant
gratification or get get get get get you
know
um
there's very little waiting for things
even grades you don't wait for grades
you find them you take a test you find
out the grade immediately right you know
you take a standardized test you can log
on and get the grades when you're done
with the test absolutely
um I'm not I want to interject though
what I'm thinking more about is the fact
that
people's work ethic isn't High anymore
like they want the instant gratification
but also there there's a laziness that's
instilled because I think because
everything comes so easy the swiping to
find the date to or you know Amazon to
like you know when you want to buy
something but there's also this like
other like layer of just you know
work-life balance and this and that and
like I know you're all about balance so
this is going to be kind of hard for me
to kind of explain to talk to you about
but like is there such a thing when
you're when you're really trying to like
build you know
like you're trying to build your career
at the beginning and really want to
strive and be successful isn't there an
imbalance just naturally of course right
of course but
balance is the wrong balances doesn't
mean even
oh okay right
um uh you know it's not about equals but
Equitable okay right like great
relationships aren't equal they're
Equitable right an equal relationship is
I cook you cook I clean you clean I do
the dishes you do the dishes that's you
know that's an equal relationship an
equitable relationship is I'll cook you
do the dishes
I'll put the kids to bed you take out
the garbage that's an equitable
relationship right we're not doing the
same things it's not equal but it feels
balanced right everybody's okay with the
distribution of Labor right and we have
to remember that there's nothing for
free not there's nothing in this world
that comes for free and everything that
you get
comes at a cost
always and the only question is is the
cost worth it right and so if you want
to achieve like there's a lot people
who've done extremely well and the
question is at what cost what we're
talking about is is the desire to have
without paying for it you know which is
I want this but I'm not willing to pay
the cost right so for example working
really hard to get something I want to
achieve this the cost is I'm going to
have a couple sleepless nights I'm going
to work a little harder I'm going to
miss out on some social events I might
be a little bit exhausted now and then
but for me that's worth the cost
because of what I'm trying to accomplish
and so I think what we're seeing is a is
a is a is a misunderstanding of the of
the cost of benefit
uh equation
and and by the way it's not for us to
say whether the cost that was worth it
to us is worth it to other people it may
not be right and that's not for us to
decide I think where where we do get to
interject is if you want to have
something like what we've done but you
aren't willing to pay any cost and make
any sacrifice that's a complicated
scenario right
um because ain't nothing for free 100
I'm so happy that you said that because
that is a hundred percent act in my
opinion completely accurate but it's not
for us to determine what someone's
Ambitions should be either like if
somebody is totally fine right you know
here right and whatever here is defined
as I mean it doesn't matter it could be
Financial it could be it could be
anything whatever it is right if
somebody's fine here and and
they don't work a lot of hours right and
this is and for them this is very happy
I think that's fantastic right I'm not
telling anybody they have to live my way
your way their way this way that way I
don't want to live one way either like I
don't need Max Max whatever other people
have because I don't want to work to
that degree either like I accept that
there's some degree of things that I
can't achieve because I'm just not
willing to do the work absolutely I'm
okay with that and Europe but you
already are self-aware enough to know
that about yourself what size wide open
it's eyes wide open but I think it's I
think what you're saying is basically
what I'm saying is that there's a there
is a cost you can't have it all if you
want this sometimes like when people say
oh you know you can have this war you
can be a like for a woman you could be a
CEO and be a Powerhouse but also have
like three kids and be a wonderful mom
and then be an amazing wife like
something always has to give so like to
me that's like just being honest and
being real a friend of mine who is a
senior executive at a big company a mom
you know she had kids she told me very
early on when I was she was like my work
Mom like I was entry level and she took
me under her Wing she was a partner at
the company and I remember I don't
remember how the conversation came up
but she I remember her telling me she
goes any woman who decides uh to be a to
want a career and to be a mother to be a
working mother has to get used to the
idea that you're always going to
disappoint someone
you just have to get used to it they're
going to disappoint your company because
you want to stay home with your kids or
you're going to disappoint your kids
because you want to work late like you
just have to get comfortable the fact
that you're always going to disappoint
someone or sometimes you disappoint
yourself right you know like but these
but the point is what she was there was
another way of saying there's a cost for
the choices I've made and by the way you
can always change those choices too
right like that's also on the table like
none of these things are are you know
one and done right in stone right and I
think that's one of the things that kova
did for a lot of us which is we went
back and reevaluated some of the choices
we made and thought ooh
I can recalibrate you know and I think
that's kind of what we're going through
right now which is this weird period of
you sort of like
sort of nobody's really exactly sure how
the working world is going to net out
and I think I think there's a massive
recalibration happening you know some of
which shows up as you know debate over
do we come back to work do we not come
back to work is it hybrid what does that
even look like how does that even work
what does hybrid look like what are the
rules of hybrid what do you think of
hybrid what do you think of all these
rules like you're I mean you go into
companies talking about this all the
time right yes it is causing a lot of
stress for a lot of companies I mean
it's you know and I and I get asked the
question all the time which is what are
we supposed to do the answer is I have
no clue you know the you know the the
only thing I know I think we can say for
certain is that flexibility is here to
stay where it used to be can I you know
you ask permission to work from home
next Friday because my kids are going to
be home from school and now you can just
email in the mornings I'm working from
home today and everybody's fine with it
I think that's here to stay but but the
exact balance I don't think any anybody
got it figured out yet and how you
enforce the balance I don't think
anybody's figured out yet and I don't
think the right is going to suit every
company either like right you know I
think it's going to be different
especially if you have people that have
to come to work you're in manufacturing
or retail or something and people who
don't have to come to work because
they're still Accounting in back office
in those companies does it create a
divided system of haves and have-nots
you know people who have agency and
people who don't That's not healthy for
a culture either so I don't think we
know yet and I think it's a bit of chaos
right now combined with the fact that
many of us are you know sort of going
through our own recalibrations going
what kind of Life do I want
um yeah so I think it's a bit of a mess
but it's okay it'll it'll it'll organize
I think chaos is great because chaos is
an opportunity for creativity right
because without chaos you have to break
something to change something right now
you don't have to break it you can just
change it so great opportunity you think
so because I think that you get to
reinvent work we get to reinvert
reinvent would work what work is true
but they would have what happens if
everybody's there's like so much there's
so much Flex like the pendulum has swung
so far what happened to collaboration
and yeah it'll all suffer this is what
happens and socialize again faster to
socialization people are becoming like a
ton into like automaton yeah yes because
everything is like a screen or this like
we now don't even know like what people
even really look like in real life we
definitely don't know how tall they are
yeah
um
uh
nice nice uh what do you call it we had
somebody on our team that was hired
doing code
and
I'd never met her until you know a year
into working with us right and when I
remember she's six one I was like what
though like I had no idea like we're
always the same height when I look at
you on the screen exactly
um so
you're right the pendulum did swing the
other way but that's what happens yes
it's a reaction there's a cost for that
reaction and it'll come back that's why
I say it's a sort of a chaotic time
um uh uh but I think that
um
you know we can whine about it or we can
say okay how do we sort of how can we
have some say of what it could be and
let's have those conversations Out Loud
Let's talk about the costs let's talk
about the advantages and disadvantages
like yes it's great to have flexibility
to work from whatever you want
but
um it does damage collaboration and
brainstorming like creativity is going
to go down because everybody's so
excessively polite on zoom and they mute
themselves when they're not speaking and
if you've ever had a brainstorming
meeting no that's not how it is it's
messy and noisy and you interrupt each
other and nobody's offended when you
interrupt each other and you're like oh
yeah I have an idea and it's and that's
what produces great brainstorming
totally so you know I've started when I
have it doesn't work with big meetings
but I've started doing with small
meetings where I make everybody keep
their microphones
uh on
and I encourage just speaking out like
it's a real meeting you know which yeah
it does help
um it does help
um but not the same as being in person
does not is of course not you and I
talking over a zoom would not feel
exactly like this you can't create human
connection when there's a screen but I
think we all know that like that's not
that's not the news I think the news is
well okay what are we gonna do right and
you know some people are saying well I
don't care about that because I value my
freedom I value my this and I value my
where I want to live and you know it's
sort of like I think the if anything you
know there's sort of a weird selfishness
to it all you know and it goes back to
what we're saying which is I want I want
everything I want my cake and I want to
eat it and I want everything and
everything's gonna go my way and you
know having it my way is a very Noble
aspiration just unrealistic right you
know it's like you have kids you love to
get all your sleep you know it's like
it's not how it works right and it goes
back to what we were just saying a
minute ago which is there's a cost for
everything and uh um but that's okay I
think I think
I think those lessons will be learned
you know I said some some things ago as
I said things on another podcast
recently that when I read the comments
like people were like lashing out which
I thought was so fascinating what did
you say so I basically talked about how
um this young excuse younger it's not
completely but excuse younger have
become very comfortable quitting
it's become uh normalized
um where
um when you and I were younger even if
you didn't like your job you had to stay
for at least a year because otherwise
you destroy your resume totally yeah it
just it was it is what it is like you
just had to suck it up for a year right
by the way I saw you talk about that on
something and I was that's one of the
things I was like oh my God exactly
that's so true so I and this is what I
talked about and I talked about how
where quitting has become so uh
normalized that there's a lot of people
excuse younger
um who quit very quickly you know after
three months or four months you maybe
they like they're having a bad week or
they they're their confrontation
avoidant and don't ask for a raise so
it's just easier to quit or maybe they
got in trouble and they're like you know
my boss and like I'm gonna quit
okay you know and so you know
what ends up happening is Flash Forward
five years is going to be a portion of
the of the workforce that over the
course of five years has had nine or ten
jobs and any employer is going to look
at a resume and be like yeah no I'm not
going to take the you're so smart you're
brilliant but I can't take the risk you
know or
they have been in the workforce for five
years but they've only really had about
seven months of work experience because
they keep starting again and they know
what it's like to work in calm Waters
but they have yet to really sit through
and weather a storm you know uh because
going through going through a hard time
whether you're having a hard time at
work or whether the company's having a
hard time like you learn skills in that
that are valuable to companies and by
the way they're valuable to you right
and so and I said these things and I
couldn't believe the backlash
you know in the comments like what well
you know you know that I was speaking
from the point of an employer and you
know uh that that's about exploitation
and I'm like I I you know I'm not and I
think there's a
sort of a a misunderstanding
um and a quick to judge like I I have no
judgment in what I'm saying it's it's an
observation it's an observation that
that younger people generally are more
comfortable quitting more quickly right
and if we go back again this is going to
be our recurring theme what's the cost
of that yes he's like yes it has
benefits absolutely why should you put
up with a job you don't like get out of
there sure absolutely you know yes you
you know your your your your boss is not
the world's most fantastic leader not a
bad person but not a great leader sure
get out of there you know I have it
sounds great but there's a cost and I'm
not sure those costs are being weighed
but there will be an accounting in five
years
and that's all I'm saying which is just
be aware just go in with eyes wide open
think of the long game you can still
make the decision
you can still make the decision I'm not
saying make or don't make the decision
I'm seeing I'm saying be cognizant of
the long game
you know and people people I I see to me
that is so absurd that's how you build
like do hard things is how you build
resilience and and mental toughness and
I'm not asking anybody and you're not
and I know you're a toxicity you know of
course not I I I I I do but don't you
don't you do things like do you think I
want to work out every single day and
like grind on that out no but if I want
to if I see the results that I get at
the end of the day or the end of the
year or whatever we're saying you put up
with the stuff that you don't want to do
for the long-term gain of what you can
get that there is an equation right
right
um and as I said I think that when we
when we think of equations
we think of the short-term benefit yes
and we that's fine there's always
short-term benefits and liabilities
there's no problem with that but we also
have to consider the long-term benefits
and liabilities
especially it's in in in in if we
consider relationships or careers or you
know life you know these things are not
they're not
um they're not finite games right um
which is they keep going and and to
think about them as as as
um
sort of these uh
I don't know what the word is
these unique experiences that don't
exist in any context
there's a word for it I can't remember
what it is but it but um when you think
of these events as discrete packets that
have no consequences before or after
that there's no context right I think
it's just blind I mean of course there's
context there's context for everything
absolutely um
so yeah but what's it like you I think I
saw some of your talk about like was it
like self-actualization versus shared
actually yeah right yeah because we're
living in a everyone wants to be
self-actualized yeah and we're taking
that people now it's like a very selfish
me me oriented world right what did you
mean by shared like can you explain that
a little bit yeah I mean I think that
especially the United States over
indexed on the concept of rugged
individualism and you can see it play
out and how we you know what our
guidance counselors tell us what our
bosses tell us you know the incentive
structures in our and reward systems in
our universities and in our businesses
which is it's all individual performance
right
um and we pay little to no consideration
to teamwork or did you serve the team or
did you serve yourself
um and that has cost you know right to
the team
um and uh you know it it basically goes
to uh uh Maslow's higher hierarchy of
knees which is where the
self-actualization
uh came from that's the top of here so
so yeah I I think maslav was wrong
right so Maslow hierarchy of needs the
base of the pyramid is food and shelter
you know that you need that first and
the third rung up is human relationships
and at the top of the period of pyramid
is self-actualization so you're supposed
to work your way up the hierarchy of
needs until you can get to
self-actualization and what Maslow's
mistake is is that he only thinks of us
as individuals but what he fails to
consider is that we're also
simultaneously members of groups every
single one of us every single day lives
in Paradox you know we are individuals I
want my own identity I want my own
individuality I want to self-express all
of those things all true and
simultaneously I'm a member of a family
I'm a member of a church I'm a member of
a team I'm a member of a company I'm a
member of you know uh synagogue
synagogue whatever you know like I have
membership you know and I have
responsibility
it as a in the group right and there's a
debate do I put myself first the
sacrifice of the group or do I put the
group first of the sacrifice of myself
and there's a and and some will say
there's a whole school of thought that
says you always prioritize yourself
um because if you don't help yourself
you can't help others and they always
get the same stupid analogy which is
when you're on a plane you put your mask
on before you can help somebody else
that's a crashing plane not a good
analogy right this crashing playing with
no with with no air in it right correct
you have to put yourself first correct
right that's not a good analogy for life
right
um but then there's a school of thought
that says no you have to help others
always first otherwise the group will
never be there to help you but that's
martyrdom and sometimes you get to it to
a point where you actually do destroy
yourself because you're trying so hard
to help everybody else put everybody
else first right the answer is both it's
a paradox it's complicated and so where
Maslow got it wrong is he failed to
consider us as members of groups which
is why he put food in shelter first
which is true as an individual but I've
never heard of anybody Dying by suicide
because they were hungry right die by
suicide because you're lonely which is
the third thing up but it seems more
important than food right and so how
selfish is it that we work to
self-actualization and we metaphorically
literally sit on well not literally and
metaphorically but metaphorically sit on
top of a pyramid looking down at all the
unself-actualized people
how selfish that we live a life so that
we can get to the top of a pyramid as
opposed to Shared actualization like how
do we take as many people with us to
find Joy love fulfillment safety
come let's go on that journey together
to the top of the pyramid is that not my
responsibility as a member of the of the
group you know to take as many people
with me as possible to look out for them
you know to take care of the weak ones
and not let the strong ones get too
ahead of themselves because we're part
of a team of by the way the thing that
I'm describing is called leadership but
isn't that what we're supposed to be
doing
you know we have an entire section in
the Bookshop called self-help and we
have no section of the Bookshop called
help others and we have entire
industries that are literally telling us
how we can find happiness how we can
find love how we can find the perfect
job and yet no one is teaching us how we
can help our friends find love and how
we can help our friends find the job of
their dreams and how we can help our
friends find happiness and that is a
skill set
equal to the skill set of helping
oneself they have they both have value
I'm not rejection I'm not rejecting
taking care of oneself but I'm telling
you that there's also
another part of this equation and I
think that we've we've overdone this one
and you see it reflected now you know uh
even even the way we've commercialized
and made we've miraculously made things
like meditation and yoga selfish right
how can I I I love it I feel
I feel so I feel so present right it's
like I feel present now yes there are
absolutely benefits to meditation we
know the benefits of taking care of
oneself and finding that mindfulness
right
um uh we know all those those those
social and medical benefits
but the reason we practice meditation
think about it in meditation meditation
as you sit still
you focus on one thing whether it's a
mantra or your breath or whatever it is
and you put everything else out of your
mind and if you have a thought you label
it a thought and you say I'll deal with
that later
and you find this incredible calm and
peacefulness that comes the reason we
call it a practice is so you can
practice it for others not just for
yourself yes we know the benefits to you
have you ever taken that practice and
given it to others so when they're
sitting there telling you their problems
that you're not just thinking of the
thing that you want to say next you're
not just thinking how do you can fix
their problems where they tell you about
their great day and you interrupt them
and tell them that you're a great day
but rather because you've been
practicing this mindfulness that you can
sit completely quietly focused on one
thing and one thing only is what they're
telling you and if something goes bang
over there you actually don't turn your
head because you're so focused and you
have a thought you label it a thought
and you put it out of your mind as I'll
deal with it later because right now I'm
focused on the person I'm with at the
end of that interaction you will know
you were present when they tell you you
were we are not present until someone
tells us we are present and they will
say things like thank you for listening
they will say things like I feel heard
they will say thank you for being
present with me holding space for me
congratulations all that hard work
you've been doing meditating was now
also for the benefit of another and what
we also know
is that the Medical Science on this
for all the benefits of mindfulness for
oneself are multiplied by 10 when you do
it for someone else
by ten service Omar Branson talks about
this um he has a he he specializes in
gratitude right yes and and he talks
about the difference the way he labels
it is mindfulness versus uh heartfulness
you know and and he and I talked about
how mindfulness is about me and I'm in
my head but heartfulness is about
someone else right and and he has the
data that there's 10x medical benefit
to the service of mindfulness rather
than the taking of mindfulness it has
benefit and I'm not saying no you're
right not do this I'm saying also do
this you know I I know the I know the
study you're talking about it's actually
I I it's in my this book that I just
wrote but it's about I I say not service
I say the word uh gratitude because
people think that if they journal the
Gratitude gratit they Journal uh that
that's having gratitude but it's
actually the act of like telling
somebody thank you or sort of like
basically turning it on its head to
somebody else the um effects are like
tenfold which is I think the same is the
same thing and and in our fast-paced you
know
social media world I think we've
conflated some of these human
[Music]
practices
and we've sort of sort of mixed them up
a little bit you know I one of my
favorites is people who put these
beautiful posts on Instagram with them
as babies being held by their dad and
you know and it says happy birthday dad
or Happy Father's Day daddy your dad's
not on Instagram like who are you
telling
like it's like who you like your dad
what did you call your dad like like
happy you're the best sister happy
siblings day did you did you call your
sibling you know I I find that funny
um I find it so phony and is
what I call it and and or or that we
talk about vulnerability when you know
you talk about your breakup or the hard
thing you're going through and you're
sitting by yourself in your room talking
to your phone by the way that may not be
the first take and it might be the
fourth take that I'm doing this because
it was sort of the lighting was bad
um and I put that on I put that on Tech
talk and I say vulnerability for
everyone to learn from that's not
vulnerability that's broadcasting now go
say those exact words to a person
which is way more difficult
and I think for us to practice true
vulnerability which is to sit with
somebody whether in pain or Joy which is
to sit across from them or to the very
minimum pick up the telephone versus a
text and say I just want you to know I
love you and I care about you and you
are one of my best friends and I will be
there for you in thick and thin no
matter what and I know that you would be
there for me and I just want you to know
how grateful I am for this friendship
and for you
right do that to somebody or sit in pain
with them and say I'm struggling you and
I have had a fight and I am up every
night because of it it hurts me and I
don't know where it came from the words
you said to me the other day Hurt Me
Like a Knife right go say that to the
person as opposed to broadcasting it
because that doesn't actually it gives
you a salve it makes you feel a little
bit better for the few minutes you've
done it does it or is it more for the
other people on social yeah it has to
have some benefits of myself or a
follow-up I mean that would be really
cynical of us to say but I I have to
believe it has something very Optimist I
never said I was there
um I'm still cynical though yeah uh oh
yeah the you know
there of course there's some benefit but
the problem is it's a short-term benefit
whereas you know you and I both know
that to get in the with someone
professionally personally to get in the
with someone
almost always you come out with Clarity
better understanding and usually a much
better relationship almost always you
know struggle is some of the best thing
that can happen in a relationship
um uh shared hardship
actually releases oxytocin in our bodies
you know everybody's all about dopamine
and oxytocin and oxytocin comes from
many many reasons
some healthy some not healthy but one of
the healthy ways that we get oxytocin a
shared hardship you know have somebody
go take some Marines and put them in
combat together those Marines will come
back in love with each other they will
love each other the shared experience
shared hardship in particular you know
shared hardship shared struggle actually
create strong bonds you know if there's
a hurricane that comes through all of a
sudden who you voted for it doesn't
matter at all I got you right I got you
I totally agree I mean do you spend I
mean how much time do you spend on
social media you have a lot of followers
and all that other Jazz are you
constantly looking at your phone are you
constantly doing all that stuff like
what's your ratio well I mean
I have all my notifications turned off
on my telephone except for texts and
phone calls
um I get zero notifications if I got an
email I get zero notifications of
anybody posted or liked or anything on
any social media ever
right so I don't have that dopamine you
know ding ding I don't have it
um uh but like anyone you know I can go
down a rabbit hole if I'm feeling a
little bit down or lonely of course I go
swipe you know swiping for for goodness
and my goodness the algorithm on Tech
talk you know I'll just spend 10 minutes
and two hours later you know tell me
about this this to me is there's some
funny talented entertaining people out
there amazing and they're brilliant and
wonderful and that algorithm is
astonishing uh it is astonishing it is
astonishing it is astonishing how good
it is and how it just feeds me
everything I want to see better than
anything else but I'm also fully with
like I can't do it that often like I
know that if I open that Tick Tock app I
am fully aware that I am not in control
of myself 100 I am I am fully aware that
time will evaporate and and I know that
I'm gonna like like I'm gonna like sit
in bed and like and all of a sudden I'm
gonna stop because I'm falling asleep
and I realize it's one o'clock in the
morning totally so I know not to turn
the app on but but it's I would say that
my social media interaction is mostly
healthy only because I have all the
notifications turned off so I don't even
know I don't even I don't even the
buttons the count of how many emails you
have
I I have none on my little envelope on
my phone yeah it's blank not because I
don't have emails it's because I only
find out if I'm like oh I think I'll
check my email now open up the email app
and I see all the new emails oh good so
I don't I don't have notifications
turned on so you basically controlled
your environment that way so you know
that you have a that's you're taking
away the ability to kind of go down
those and my phone is always my the
ringer is always turned off it doesn't
even vibrate so I literally don't know
if anything's coming unless I pick it up
to look so I don't have that dopamine
thing
um I make a practice of when I'm out
with friends that I put my phone on a on
a different seat I put it out of I don't
put it on a table I put it Out Of Reach
I can't see it
on purpose on purpose on purpose because
I understand the addictive qualities of
the device and so you know it's like the
first thing you do with an alcoholic is
you take all the alcohol out of the
house because we just don't have that
kind of willpower it's not because
they're weak it's because none of us
have that kind of willpower to resist
and so to think that we're so strong
that we can resist the dopamine powers
of of our cell phones and social media
you're just wrong right you know so so I
I put it out of sight that's a good idea
or or sometimes give it to my friend can
you carry my phone for me do that a lot
that's a great idea just because it's
like because I because we're living in
that kind of world now which is that's
why I don't know how we're you know you
we always find like you know the
pendulum swings but because we're
getting more and more addicted because
there's more platforms like every day
there's a new platform that comes up and
a new thing that happens where do we
come back to a place where like kind of
like we're I don't know 15 20 years ago
we didn't have this type of like same
addiction where there wasn't social
media well I mean there were other
things to get addicted to well what were
we addicted to alcohol people are still
people are still doing that the Phantom
that was being sold right now it's true
it's not like like it's not like the
world was so you know let's not be
Pollyanna so the world is perfect and
nobody had any addictions no no no but
you're but you're right I mean
um the amount of uh I think is it I
can't remember the statistic I just read
recently is it deaths by alcohol or just
we all know the amount of drinking that
went up during coveted skyrocketed but I
think deaths by alcohol have also gone
up did yours like what did you did I die
from alcohol no no no no and when from
coven how did did you tweak or modify
your habits or your your life at all
like at all or I don't know how to
answer that question because I think all
of our lives were tweaked no no but but
like now that we've kind of come out the
other end or other other way oh oh has
anything remained yeah what have you
done like what have you have you like
did you kind of increase your Fitness
level did you stop working as much like
what's your I want to know what you do
every single day I want to know what
time you wake up how you wake up what
you eat what you don't eat so one of the
magical things that happened during
covet was
um my niece and nephew were little kids
that I saw two or three times a month
and then I went to having family dinner
with them every single night
you know and so my sister's family and I
we sort of we were back and forth
between our two homes and we had family
dinner every single night every family
yeah yeah every single Oh you mean
during covered you did it yeah and so I
loved it and
um and we have tried as a family to
preserve
uh that as much as possible where we
have Friday night Sushi night for
example as you know there's occasional
exceptions where you know
they have a game or I'm traveling but
for the most part that that Friday night
Sushi night is sacred I won't make plans
because I gotta have dinner with the
kids and uh and I really like it I
really like it
um so I've tried to cling on to some of
those things
um I've you know it goes I I have it
waxes and wanes
um but uh I've tried to maintain a
better balance of uh
of travel you know being away because
families become more important I mean
it's always been important but being
present for family
um you say family your sister your kid
yeah
uh okay I gotta ask you a bunch of like
leadership questions because that's I
have a bunch
um what are the two most powerful
success habits people should cultivate
in order to go get ahead in life
um
uh good question uh number one is
curiosity
um the the the very difficult thing of
replacing judgment with curiosity
uh makes for good leadership
um curiosity also leads to humility the
best definition of humility I ever heard
was a guy named Bob Gaylor who said
don't confuse humility for meekness he
said he says humility is being open to
the ideas of others
um you can have a big ego but you can
still be like all right let's hear your
idea you know as opposed to just
shooting the idea down right um You
don't have to agree with it but you can
be curious about it so I think replacing
learning to replace curiosity uh
judgment with curiosity and and
practicing curiosity makes you come
keeps you humble
you don't have all the best ideas for
example other people are smart too right
um I think is one and the other one is
the equally difficult practice to learn
to say I don't know or I need help
um I think are absolutely essential
do you you said I I mean you talk about
this a lot about empathy power of
empathy and that's like a key component
for leadership yeah and that you that
you've noticed that most powerful
leaders have this
well a good one the good ones the good
ones a lot of powerful things I was
gonna say that word was not the right
words most of the good ones can you
teach empathy or can someone learn to be
more empathetic sure sure absolutely 100
um it is a practice it is a skill uh
like so many others
um right I think empathy again starts
with curiosity yeah you know
um
you know it's somebody's underperforming
instead of labeling them stupid or lazy
or unmotivated or snowflakes
to ask the question I wonder what's
going on in their life I hope they're
okay that's empathy and then to actually
say to them are you okay you know
um negative narratives are you know
they're dangerous at every level of a
company you know sometimes right you
know um
you know uh Rank and file will start a
narrative about leadership they're
they don't care and sometimes
leadership starts a narrative about an
employee and they're stupid they're lazy
and the problems that'll affect how we
treat each other and we'll start looking
for evidence to validate our our
narratives yeah it's very easy to
interrupt you simply say I wonder what
else it could be
you know and it's important for you know
if you're with a team and you start
on leadership somebody could
say I wonder what else it could be you
know maybe they're under stress or maybe
maybe that we don't know what's going on
you know and same thing with leadership
which is one in a group somebody starts
labeling somebody or even if you're
doing it by yourself
you say I wonder what else it could be I
wonder what else is going on in their
life and you can make a list so so you
know
you know they're lazy that that still on
the list that could be it sure okay or
maybe there's something going on in
their personal life that we don't know
about maybe there's some families drama
that they're dealing with that we don't
know about maybe we've given them too
much
um uh
um work maybe they're overworked and
burned down maybe maybe we've we've
maybe they're under trained they don't
know what they're doing and we've we
have a culture where it's too difficult
to ask for help like it could be 50
things
you know it could still be the one that
you think but it could be other things
too and the point is is now when you
talk to that person you're operating
with empathy you're operating with
curiosity you know
um so yeah of course it's practicable
yeah it's Pro and learnable yeah you get
better at it like anything you do it
more it becomes second nature right you
know but I feel when people are uh like
leading I think you talk about this too
like they're people who are leaders and
people who lead there's a big difference
between the two right
um Can someone learn to be a good like a
a good leader because I feel like look
at you talk about
um let's talk about Elon Musk for
example right he's like a very powerful
man obviously I mean I wouldn't think he
would be considered a good a great
leader but everybody does want to work
with him and be there and be around
people people like to be around
successful people that's like human
nature so then how is it that when I
think you talk a lot about
um if you have a why obviously that's
your whole thing people that's when
people work harder when they they want
to that's when an organization does
exceptionally well do you think that
SpaceX or even Amazon or any of these
people like that I can't imagine those
leaders having that type of I guess they
do have the vision
but they're not exactly necessarily
great leaders I guess there is a group
well that's my own question yeah I mean
well we can talk about
um you know leadership has nothing to do
with Personality yeah Steve Jobs not the
nicest guy in the world right
um but you talk to people who worked
there during the Steve Jobs days that he
pushed them to do the best work of their
lives right you know you know people
show up with their fancy resumes or
wherever else they worked I'd be like
well I built this and I invented that
and you know they would say the same
thing which is we don't care what you've
done we care what you're gonna do right
you know and so for people who like to
be pushed to do better work they loved
working there
right you know it's it's not it's not it
goes back to you know no do we share the
same beliefs which isn't it that culture
is not for everyone and and he by the
way Steve Jobs invented a total of zero
of the products that Apple made he came
up with none of them right the ideas for
those products came from within the
teams so so he's not the genius because
he came up with all the ideas he was the
genius because he pushed people to come
up with ideas and and and he knew how to
contextualize them and share them with
the world right
um
um he understood that that he understood
what good looked like so was he in the
nicest guy in the world no was he a
great leader yeah I mean for heaven's
sakes after a multi-billionaire died who
flies in private jets everywhere he goes
you know like he cannot relate to our
lives we cannot relate to his life after
he died people laid flowers at a retail
store to mourn the loss of a CEO like
just think about that for just crazy I
know right and that can only happen if
someone gives us Something to Believe In
if somebody gave us something to feel a
part of whether you're an employer or a
customer you know or a spectator right
so so the evidence is demonstrated by
the fact that he gave people something
to stand for right yeah or to belong to
um what very often happens to a lot of
leaders is
um sometimes they start to believe their
own press they start to believe that
because they've had a string of success
that everything they do will be
successful
um
it was described to me recently by a
friend that you have a bag of balls you
know of equal number of red uh red balls
of blue balls I haven't changed that one
let's go with let's go with red bulls
and green bowls
um
I love it it was a dirty mind yeah
so red balls I love it very cool we'll
stay Christmas oriented uh Red Bulls and
green balls and you know you put your
hand in and you pull out a red ball and
you pull your hand in and you pull out a
red ball and you pull out your hand and
you put that Ed eight red balls in a row
okay and you're just like I'm a freaking
star I'm like the Red Bull Pro except
the opportunity for failure they have
the opportunity for playing at the other
club now has gone up the odds because
it's equal number right yeah and so
that's kind of life which is these these
these folks have had you know massive
success they keep playing but they
wrecking what they're failing to
recognize is failure could be the next
could be the next pull you know
absolutely and um and unfortunately the
good ones surround themselves with teams
of Rivals people who disagree with them
and the ones who start to believe
they're in hype and have gone off the
deep end surround themselves with people
who only agree with them uh uh only
people who agree with them
um validating their genius every day and
uh
and that that
doesn't work well for the long term it
doesn't work well you'd actually you
said the word rival not in the same way
but in your I guess this was written a
few years ago the infinite game but you
do talk about worthy rivals
who is your worthy rival I mean I have a
bunch you know uh uh worthy Rivals so
let's define what where the arrival is
first yes
um I know the story you want me to tell
um
uh
so there is another
author who does what I do he writes
books he gives talks he's extremely
smart
and uh you know
I hate them
[Laughter]
you know my my hatred for him is
completely irrational I'm aware of that
um he's always been very civil to me
when I've seen him at events very kind
um he never done anything to hurt me
that I know of he's a good guy I just
have a rational hatred and as a result
of my contempt I'm very very very
competitive with him so I will regularly
go on Amazon and look at his book
ranking and then I'll immediately look
at my book ranking and if he's ahead I'm
angry and if I'm ahead I'm smug
um mind you I checked no one else's
rankings it's like it's like as if
there's only two people writing books I
check no one else's rankings just his
right I'm competitive with him
um we had the opportunity to speak at
the same event and I don't mean like me
in the morning him in the afternoon I
mean like we were gonna be on the stage
at the same time interviewed by I'm
gonna be interviewed
and the interviewer thought it would be
fun if we introduced each other
and I went first
and I turned to him and I said um
you make me really insecure
all of your strengths are all of my
weaknesses and whatever your name comes
up I get really uncomfortable
and he turned to me and he said funny
I feel the same about you
the reason I was so competitive with him
the reason I had this irrational
contempt had nothing to do with him it
had to do with me because his strengths
show me my weaknesses it's too difficult
to look at myself and say that I'm weak
here and it's much easier to say I hate
him and I'm going to beat him right now
the funny thing is after that experience
there was a total catharsis all of that
negativity all of that competitive
Spirit completely went away and he and I
now friends and regularly you know
promote each other and help each other
um just hang out together
we live in different cities but yeah if
we're in the same place we'll definitely
hang out together
um
and I and this is what worthy Rivals are
worthy rivals or other players in the
game whose strengths reveal to your
weaknesses and instead of trying to
compete against them because you can't
beat them there's no such thing as
winning in this game like what am I
there's like like what I sell more books
am I the winner you know no right it
means nothing I pick an arbitrary thing
what if it's social media following like
it could be anything what if it's you're
winning anyway like who knows like you
know I mean like the point is it's
stupid and arbitrary right it is
arbitrary he makes 10 times more money
than me am I winning or losing like like
who the hell knows what's your metric
right it's just it's stupid the point is
the comparisons are stupid right
um but what is valuable is that when you
pick players who are better at one or
many things than you are that because
their strengths reveal to your
weaknesses the opportunity is to either
work on those weaknesses to get better
to become a better player yourself or to
partner with them
those strengths and those weaknesses
balance each other off
they they uh negate each other
um and so I'm not competitive I have no
competitors but I definitely have worthy
Rivals people who are really good at
what they do and I have such love and
admiration for them and I used to get
insecure about it but now I'm grateful
because it helps me be a better player
so I'm a great believer in worthy Rivals
and the same goes for companies by the
way you know for companies to compare
each other themselves to each other and
say we're better based on what revenues
profit market share a number of
employees like based on what like based
on what time frame this year total the
next 10 years like it's all arbitrary
and nonsense right not to mention the
fact that most companies are taken down
not by the competitor that they're
obsessed with but the one they didn't
know of right you think Myspace even had
any idea that Facebook even existed you
know it doesn't happen you think that
the big TV studios and movie studios
were paying any attention to Netflix
exactly you know you think the big three
car companies were worried about what
Tesla was going to do to upset their
Marketplace like nobody's looking at the
upstarts they're looking at each other
so further reinforcing the Folly of of
arbitrary competition in in business or
in Life or you know in any in any sort
of these infinite games
um so yeah I'm a great believer in
worthy Rivals we should have them
because it makes us better so just is
this person still your worthy since you
kind of had this catharsis do you have
he was he was my competitor before right
now he's my word no no here's your okay
now I have absolute respect for him and
there are things that he doesn't like
ugh I could do better but there I have
many do you have another do you have a
competitor now that you look at I have
no competitors all worthy Rivals I have
many worthy Rivals who sometimes they're
better at this one thing or they're
better at these two things or they're
better at those things and even when we
do something at our at our company like
when we are going to like I mean come up
with anything like we're gonna redo our
website like something mundane we'd be
like okay who are the worthy Rivals like
who's doing it really well that we want
to learn from you know so we always say
can somebody worthy rival this go find
somebody who's doing it better than we
are right so we can learn
we do it all the time yes I I do think
it's a healthy way to kind of keep keep
also keep yourself on your toes in a way
without oh yeah yeah of course it's like
how I still call like healthy
competition though really why you know
problem is it has the word competition
yeah you don't like the word it's like
if you have a mild melanoma review of
stage for liver cancer those things are
both called cancer but they're clearly
not the same thing absolutely so if you
use the same word the problem is it
means the same thing so you know so I
don't like saying healthy competition
because
um because it's not competition right
you don't like the word competition word
competition sets up a false game that
this is a finite game of Windows and
losers a competitor is someone to beat
right that's a competition as a winner
and a loser so let's not use those words
because they're actually incorrect
there's no winning business it doesn't
exist there's no winning Healthcare it
doesn't exist nobody's declared the
winner of career doesn't exist right
your header behind but no one's ever the
winner right so what can be a couple
other things that make someone a really
strong good leader besides see curious
is there anything else that you that
that people can work on that they can
kind of help like people who are
listening who are entrepreneurs who are
now starting to lead a team of some kind
uh
anything else that you would think that
would help people in that type of new
yes position or and or somebody who's
not new to the position you know there's
a there's a concept that has been lost
in our modern society and that is a that
is the concept of Honor
we don't talk about honor anymore honor
is not nothing to do with
trustworthiness or a liability or
intelligence it's something very
different right
so an example of honor is um
um
it's when someone takes advantage of
maybe you've had a string of bad luck
let's say you've you've uh let's say
um
you know
you've lost a bunch of clients and it's
you're going through a really hard time
and you need all the help that you you
you all that you can find in somebody on
your team comes to you and says
um I want to renegotiate my contract
because somebody gave them some bad
advice that you've got all the cards
you've got all the leverage you should
use it so taking advantage when someone
is
hurting for self-gain is dishonorable
that person may be smart that person may
be very trustworthy that person may be
reliable but they are not honorable
honor is about ethics
right and too often the standard these
days is the law it's like I didn't break
any laws like you know a a
pharmaceutical company that raises the
price of an essential drug a thousand
percent fifteen hundred percent yes it's
not illegal it is not illegal but it is
unethical it is dishonorable
and I for one only want to work with
people who have honor
um who understand that it's I'd rather
lose money in the short term and do the
right thing
then make money
um uh uh unethically or to put to be to
act selfishly and take advantage of
someone's pain or someone's uh
disadvantage that is dishonorable and uh
I choose to build my my business and be
around people who are honorable I think
we need honor back in business I think
it's gone missing for a while I like
that because it's all become so
selfishly driven yeah Thunder is the
opposite of selfishness it is would
honor be like Integrity too includes
Integrity I think you have to have it's
a component of right again that person
may have integrity until they decide to
put themselves first you know are they
out of Integrity because they are
because they have all the leverage quote
unquote you know so I think I think
call it on her because it's
that's what it is it is so yeah I think
I absolutely honor includes Integrity
absolutely one thing you said I I'm sure
for everyone always probably says this
to all the the line about how to
motivate people is like you can either
Inspire them or you can manipulate them
was it like something like that
there's two ways to motivate people you
can manipulate them or you can Inspire
them right
manipulation is easy easier
and it's usually more immediate the
impact and so we tend to rely on it we
see it in business all the time you know
we attempt to coerce people with
promotions right buy one get one free
right well that's a manipulation right I
don't really want it but I'm getting the
next one free you know
um we use fear right right
um uh the uh your children will die from
drinking tap water tune in at 11.
right right if you vote for the other
party crime will go up
you know uh it's like that's those are
fear-based it's fear-based it works
works really well
um even aspirational messages you know
uh every every every gym membership that
has ever been sold is look what you
could look like you know
um and some of them are funny and some
of them are you know pretty uh unethical
but the point is manipulations work uh
they work in the short term they become
too expensive and too exhausting over
the long term they actually do not work
over the long term
um uh the opposite is inspiration
um
it's harder takes more work there are
sometimes short-term gains but really
you're doing it for long term and when
you inspire people you get loyalty you
get trust you get those kinds of things
which the other manipulations do not
build at all can you name somebody a
leader that you've seen that does this
very well who you think is a really good
strong
inspiringly inspiring leader yeah sure
Gary Ridge who just recently retired and
CEO from WD-40 honorable honorable guy I
know WD-40 exactly uh Barry waymiller is
the company Bob Chapman the CEO of Bob
of Barry waymiller super honorable super
inspiring also lives with cause
you know
um I you know there there are there are
lots of good examples of people who are
who are not famous that's because
they're not social media they're not
they're not which is they're not they're
generally not on social media but they
are they are honorable and they give
their people Something to Believe In
and they care about their people in
their view their people as human beings
um and they recognize that they as
leaders have the responsibility to see
those around them rise they Embrace that
awesome responsibility that's what makes
them great leaders
so I wanna i i a few more minutes and I
know but you've been super generous with
your time so thank you I appreciate it I
have no idea what time it is
yeah to be honest neither do I have no
idea I think it's been out of noise
an hour and a half so yeah I guess it's
been probably longer than you were
anticipating
um
you do and believe me you can get way
more there's way more where that came
from and I have snacks I told you you
made a snack no you still have a snack
afterwards thank you very much yes I've
got some healthy ones for you uh some of
these things when I was going down the
rabbit hole with you which I have before
not just yesterday or the day before
that all these like little rules of
success that I've seen you do in these
all these different
um montages like that are on YouTube and
a few of them like these are the ones I
really love you say be the last to speak
I love that can you talk about that one
yeah that's a story about that comes
from a story about uh Nelson Mandela
Nelson Mandela is a very important
leader because
um different leaders of you differently
depending on where you go but Nelson
Mandela is universally regarded as a
great leader no matter where you go
that's true and
um he was asked by a journalist once how
did you learn to be a great leader
and he told the story of when he was a
boy
um he was actually the son of a tribal
chief
and he said he remembered going to
tribal meetings with his father and he
remembers two things one they always sat
in a circle and two his father was
always the last to speak
and if you think about it even
well-intentioned leaders we come in and
sit at the head of the table
you know and we say to the team okay
here's the problem we have this is what
I think we should do but I want to know
what you think
too late you buy us the room or you've
made people feel like your opinion
doesn't matter as opposed to sitting
down and saying here's the problem I
wonder what you think and then
being good at having a poker face you
can ask questions but not giving away if
you agree or disagree
and at the end you can have the exact
same opinion as you came in with but two
things happen a you actually get the
benefit of more input right
um so you actually may change your point
of view and
other people feel like they could
contribute and they feel like they were
contributing because they because they
were right
um so yeah it is a fantastic practice
um to literally practice being the last
to speak that is I love that one and
it's such a good one I think that's such
a great one
um outdo yourself
yeah I mean the only true competitor in
the infinite game is yourself it doesn't
matter if you beat another player in the
game the question is are you outdoing
yourself you know it's it's uh compare
it to like you know I get a kick out of
like the Olympics right so these are the
most elite athletes in the world yep and
you know maybe there's a let's say
there's a ski or an ice skater and they
got the gold medal but if you go look at
their routine they fell but it just so
happened to the person who got silver
fell twice right so are they the best
you know skier ice skater or whatever
you know in the world no in this
competition they were better than that
person that day yep right
um
um and so
I think what and and that's a finite
game you know it's a beginning middle
and end to that game it's an actual
competition in our careers there's no
beginning middle and end until you reach
the end of your career and then you
don't win career like you didn't right
you know and so the goal is not to try
and out and do other people to go let's
try to outdo yourself how am I a better
leader a a better follower and by the
way the best leaders the best followers
all the best leaders that I've ever met
believe that they are in service to
something even bigger than themselves
the best leaders are the best followers
they don't believe that the buck stops
here even the pope feel is in is in
service to something bigger than himself
he's not actually the end top end all
being the best leaders and even the ones
I mentioned you know Gary Ridge and Bob
Chapman both of them believe there
there's a higher calling both of them
believe they're in service to something
even bigger even if it's just looking
after people and making them feel like
they belong right
um so I don't use the term follower and
leader as a hierarchy right because
leaders can happen at every point of an
organization at the top of the
organization you better be a follower
um that's great
um um but you've never heard anyone say
that actually
that's true yeah but it's true yeah
um and so I think the yeah I think that
that's true which is the game that we're
in is to outdo ourselves
and we wish everybody else the best of
luck you know remember
two people can both be wildly successful
in their careers simultaneously even in
business two companies who sell the same
thing for about the same product about
the same price about the same quality
can both be wildly successful
simultaneously like there is no winner
it's a joke it's a it's a false
construction and so why not make our
products our service our work better
than we were yesterday like that's the
goal I think
your speech is actually about like when
you walk into apple or I I don't know if
you actually did it or or
uh when it was like Microsoft and like
people either focused on what the
competition was doing and that kind of
like derailed their business versus like
focusing on themselves and making their
like thinking what they're doing how
they can be better how they can
back in the Steve Ballmer days Steve
Ballmer was obsessed with beating apple
right and he sort of very publicly said
you know and pushed his people to make a
better iPod like we're gonna make this
right we're gonna beat Apple at their
iPod and apple wasn't competing against
Microsoft they didn't care they're all
doing themselves and so congratulations
it's true at some point
um arguably
Microsoft's Zoom uh actually was better
than Apple's iPod but for the fact that
a couple years later Apple invented the
iPhone that's right rendering both the
iPod and the zoom completely obsolete so
it makes no sense to try and make a
better product if your competition's not
even
playing the same game exactly yeah okay
one more the stack the deck is your
favor yeah
yes
um so the best way to understand that is
um I don't believe in the concept of
strengths and weaknesses everything has
context
um
um I believe we have attributes we have
characteristics that we have to know and
in some contexts those attributes are
strength and sometimes they're
weaknesses so I'll give you the example
that I like to use all the time because
it's funny is I am chronically
disorganized I'm very disorganized right
you are terribly yeah
um uh and uh
um and I've always thought of this as a
weakness so I mean what are your
weaknesses I'm disorganized right yeah
so I was at a networking event many
years ago
in the early days of my career and I met
a guy and he was like Simon you're
fantastic would love to work with you
here's my card if I was organized I'd be
texting from the cab on the way home or
emailing the next day when I get to work
you know of course but I'm disorganized
I lost the business card almost
immediately right uh two weeks later I
found the business card at the bottom of
a briefcase
and so I emailed him I said I don't know
if you remember me we met two weeks ago
you know I'd love to reconnect and he
wanted to work with me more because he
thought I was busy
he thought there was such high demand
for him yes that's why you took so long
right that's why it took so long so it
was being disorganized to strength
through a weakness the answer is it
depends in that context it was actually
a strength in different contexts when
somebody says I need you to get this
done by this time it can be a liability
so what's stacking the deck means is
putting yourself in situations where
your attributes are more likely to
reveal themselves as strengths and try
and avoid situations where your
attributes are more likely to pull you
back right so stacking the deck is not
about cheating it's about it's about
making sure that you're in the right
place that make you strong and avoiding
the places that make you weak you know
so for example if you're bad at math
don't do jobs that require lots of math
right right
yes it's it's it's I know it sounds
trite but no it's true it's sometimes
that silly you know
um like I love working
with others I love working on teams
right and so when a project comes up I
always make sure that I have a group
that I can work with because I know I'll
do better work if I work by myself it's
more stressful and the work is a lower
standard and so I know that about me I
know that I have a I I like working with
people so I stack the deck I try very
hard to work at least with one other
person or to work on on a team to
complete a project right right as
opposed to leave this to me I'll get
this done by myself some people that is
their strength to work by themselves not
me right so again
I try and stack the deck by working with
people as often as possible when I have
difficult things to do so you don't like
the word strength or weakness what word
did you say you like you like I mean we
use strength and weakness because it is
relative but yeah the point is uh it's
not that I'm so anti the words it's it's
more like recognize that it is relative
what are your okay synonym for strength
what are your like because what am I
what are my characteristics and
attributes that I have yes so I'm I like
team I like working with somebody yeah
you're a team player I'm a team player
yeah sometimes the strength sometimes a
weakness okay what otherwise
um I think out loud sometimes the
strength sometimes a weakness
right
um
you know I I think quickly sometimes too
quickly right sometimes the strength
sometimes a weakness you know sometimes
things need more consideration right
right so none of these things are are
advantages or disadvantages depends on
the context they're not inherently
strong or weak and I think we make that
mistake we label we we think we say
things about ourselves and we label them
stronger weak which is and then what
happens if you know somebody's look at
all their strength and look at all my
weaknesses now we're comparing ourselves
and we're destroying our confidence but
in the right contexts all of your
weaknesses have strengths and in the
wrong context all of your strengths are
liabilities you have a big ego that
guy's great in the wrong context it's
all it's it's it comes across as uh as
conceit right you know or uh
or or excessive you know
um so yeah I just think we have to
stop judging whether something is strong
or we can just label what it is what the
behavior is what the attribute is do you
watch TV of course okay what is your
favorite TV show it depends on you know
it depends on it depends on the context
exactly I love I love uh the Great
British Bake Off
you like that show love love because to
me that is an embodiment of what life
should be which is a competition where
we help each other ah how good is that
they're competing there is a winner yeah
people get thrown off the show every
single episode yeah and if it were an
American show they're building all this
drama and like this person hurt me and
because that's what we do in America we
make it a competition well they're
competing against each other and they
help each other yeah I mean that's what
to me the beauty of that show is it's
it's sort of like what I imagine the
world should should be like yeah okay
what's your favorite movie
I mean I'm a huge Star Wars fan so you
know I like Star Wars franchise I like
many of the TV shows that
that franchise has produced and a lot of
the movies too so what's your favorite
book
um that's a harder one for me
because I don't read much
um do you listen to books no I don't I I
have a pretty bad case of ADHD and so I
love the idea of books yeah but I
struggle to read them and everybody
thinks I'm really well read yeah that's
exactly what I would have thought I'm
not um I joke that I've written more
books than I've read which is true
and I carried a lot of Shame about it
for a long time because you know we all
think we have to be readers to be you
know to get ahead in the world or to be
smart and so I hid the fact for many
years that I didn't read books I love
buying books I love the idea of books
you know it's not that I'm anti it's
just I struggle with it right and so
I've read some of a lot of books
stacks of books next to my bed of which
I intend to get to them one day one day
but uh yeah I I prefer I I learn from
conversations and talking to people
because I struggle to read do you listen
to podcasts besides your own maybe or I
mean
again it's one of those things like I
never know when
I mean sure I've listened to episodes
here and there but I I it's not really
what you're no so I should I like the
idea of it again like because how often
do you do your podcast uh we we have
seasons um so we do it once a week you
do once a week when we were in season
yeah and then what so what do you do
when you're not traveling and doing
speaking like which what do you do for
fun
um I love the Arts okay so I'm um I love
making art and I love seeing art and are
you an artist uh I take photographs yeah
oh
um and uh
um but I like visiting I like going to
museums and Galleries and performances
and concerts and and I you know I miss
New York I miss the the the fact that
there was so much talent everywhere
um in New York I definitely miss New
York the art scene
um but I love art I'm I'm do it an
incredible amount of Lego
[Music]
of course I occasionally do with them
yeah I do do Lego with them but I have
Lego upstairs if you want to use I do
let go by myself a lot
like I have
Stacks and stacks of Lego sets that you
know I pulled them out and I do one do
you do puzzles too I like Puzzles a lot
yeah
uh like a like Liberty puzzles you know
those which ones are the Liberty ones
which ones are those I thought I knew
but like I know they're the best what
makes them so the best they're not
normal jigsaw puzzles they're wood and
they're cut out in all these wonderful
different shapes and so you know usually
when you do a jigsaw puzzle first you do
the frame you can't because there's no
there's no frame pieces like they don't
exist you have to it's kind of they're
kind of they're magical yeah Liberty
puzzles are the best oh wow I love that
do you know how to do a Rubik's Cube
just because I would think you'd be good
at it no no yeah I mean I'm plenty nerdy
but I think the I think assumptions like
I'm a big reader that does Rubik's cubes
and you know it's like it's so funny how
yeah yeah that's why I want to know no
I'm not gonna I'm not good with those
cubes no look I like New York Times
spelling bee I love word games I love I
love scratch
I went I was I had my wordal phase and I
got I'll be honest with you I got
I got sick of it what the New York Times
bought it like they started doing like
words that didn't even know were words
like right it stopped being fun exactly
you know it's just supposed to be a
silly fun game that takes five minutes
like stop you know so I actually stopped
doing Wordle I do do the New York Times
spelling bee which I love I do love
crossword puzzles I love Scrabble I love
word games I love boggles oh my God I
didn't play buggle in years I love
Buggles oh my God it's a very noisy game
but I like it it's the best game ever
that's great bottle is great boggle's
the best game ever totally inspired me I
want to play Boggle now right I played
all the time I mean I I hate to say it
but I love that game yeah no I love
vocals that's like what my favorite
pastime and then what so like when you
were younger did it just be quiet my
curiosity about you like when you were
young before all this like how were you
as a teenager like were you always very
thoughtful were you always optimistic
were you I mean you'll have to ask my
friend million friends you know uh nerdy
and dorky is probably what my sister
would say and I was I was nerdy and
dorky I mean space Sports I mean I was
athletic but not an athlete so I played
like I ran but not on the team and I
played tennis but not on the team you
know like I was athletic still and I'm
athletic but I'm not an athlete were you
a good student good enough yeah I was I
wasn't like straight a great student I
mean I was fine are you still in the
Brand Corporation as an advisor or yeah
I think I'm still on the I haven't I
haven't worked with them in a while but
yeah I think I'm still in the system
yeah sounds pretty good anyway brand is
cool yeah that's amazing Brenda's a big
very cool Think Tank and I've had
amazing meetings and amazing difficult
conversations I love people who are
smarter than me yeah I think that to me
that's like I don't read but I do love
spending time with people who are much
smarter than me I I'm invigorated by it
who is one of the people that you
thought was like who you're really
impressed by who like just really you
were inspired by that you spent time
with
I mean there's a long list
um just give me one or two well there's
names that you don't know I mean like
they there's a lot of folks in the
military who are some of the smartest
people I know right and who see the
world in a way that nobody else doesn't
asks questions in the way that nobody
else does and if I can spend all my time
with them I would be much smarter do you
have a mentor or did you have a mentor I
think it's important to have mentors I
mean I don't have a mentor anymore I
mean I've I have a group of people that
I call on a regular basis if I'm stuck
or I can't figure something out I'll I
believe in sounding boards I think
anybody who thinks that they have to
make every decision by themselves is is
setting themselves up for eventual
collapse right and I think it's very
important to get alternative points of
view
to get counsel to be open to the council
as opposed to fighting with them to
prove that you're right
um and just bounce ideas and I don't
make big or difficult decisions without
talking to somebody first my sister and
I are a very good team
um and uh rarely do I make difficult
decisions without checking in with her
first she's a very good
um she's a very good sounding board yeah
I'm very talented yeah that is so nice
does she work with you at the company
yeah yeah we work together yeah there's
three partners and my sister my sister
Sarah is one of them oh that's so nice
and my other partner and like we're just
like the three of us have like the most
complimentary skill set it's really it's
very special it's I've been looking for
something like that for a long time
that's really nice oh I love that I
think basically I've taken up like hours
of your time uh probably like two
you're falling asleep over there
um thank you I don't know what else to
say you've been a phenomenal you've been
a phenomenal guest thank you and I'm so
thankful and happy and grateful that we
that you you did this because like I
said I've been you've been requested so
many times I can't be nice thank you I
should show you my like list of like
emails and DMS people like how come you
haven't ever had Simon saying I got like
so many very nice thank you well thanks
for having me I appreciate it I really I
I love meeting you and I appreciate it a
lot of fun thank you thank you